Now, I want to cover some basic
properties of the Harris Detector.
One of the bigger questions is, can we
actually build these types of detectors,
the invariant to rotation?
That basically means is,
let's say, if I have one image and
then I have another image, and
then this image basically,
let's say I have something
like a plus sign here.
I want to be able to detect
the features of this even though,
in this image,
this plus sign might be rotated a bit.
Right.
So being able to deal with rotation
invariants is an important part, because
I still want to find the same corners.
I have a simple example like this,
but you can actually see that this can
get to be very complicated,
depending on objects.
And of course, I sometimes
want to be able to find objects.
Even with variations across the board,
on lighting and stuff like that.
So that's the next part.
Can we actually also find edges if
there is variance in image intensity?
So again,
I might have two images, and these
could be two pairs next to each other.
This one is much brighter,
and this one is much darker.
We saw examples of that when we looked
at the image pairs of the toy giraffe,
for example.
Third part that we are actually
be invariant to is Emmet scale.
What basically that means is, I have
an image and I have an object that is
here and it is of this scale,
but on the second image
I have the same object but it is,
in this case, much bigger.
So, how do we kind of
deal with the fact that
the same object might be occurring in an
image pair, but appear to be very large?
So, in essence,
now we need to start seeing,
does the Harris Detector provide
support for these type of invariances?